if your electronic device has voice
command that means the microphone has to
be listening to you all the time so that
when you speak the command it turns on
yeah now how does it translate your your
speech into into a command it records
what you say sends it to a private
company who then transcribes it to text
sends the text code back to the app the
app then runs the code the speech as the
action
that means and not every single device
but most devices that have voice
activation do it this way some do it by
requiring you to say a phrase three or
three to five times and then it just
uses the wavelength to try and match
them we don't really do that anymore
nowadays yeah they're just all on all
the time recording everything you say
and uh for your at-home device that does
all little Deeds for you there have been
numerous stories where murders have
taken place and the police have gotten
recordings of the murder from the
company who own the device